How badly do you want to have sex? Very badly, very,
very, very badly.
This is going to be interesting. How do you define virginity?
Um, it's making me think here.
We're talking like heteronormative. I it's so complicated. Um,
uh, penis.
I feel like a two year old talking about this right now. Penetrative sex,
whether that be Dick tongue, you know,
toy kind of thing.
No, that's actually an interesting question.
Cause like if you read the technical definition, I'm pretty sure. It says like,
even like oral sex is considered losing virginity and even kissing can be
considered losing your virginity.
Consent to is pretty much what defines your own virginity.
I'm a man of faith. And so I'm a believer.
And so I definitely see sex as a responsibility.
Abstinence even goes further to that. When you've been looking at a girl,
Leslie, and looking at a girl, um, in a sexual manner,
just like keeping your eyes pure.
How badly do you want to have sex? Very badly. Very,
very, very badly. I mean, I'm a teenager, but I'm on it.
I'm not a horny teenager.
I just never had the need or want to be honest. I haven't done anything.
I haven't had a boyfriend or I haven't even had my first kiss. I'm not.
On the scale of how horny am I. I'm not that horny,
but it definitely needs to happen. Definitely needs to happen.
It's something I get to look forward to. And so once that moment happens, uh,
it's going to be really amazing,
but I hear that there's like an attachment and I don't want to gain that
attachment when I'm not ready for it.
I've seen actually a lot of drama from it too. And so with me, I'm like,
I just want to get a part of that drama.
I feel like the only times I really like,
actually think about romantic relationships for sex
is like, when I see it in a movie and it's like, Oh, look at that.
And then I'm like on the couch by myself and I'm like, Oh, that would be nice.
Why are you a Virgin straight up? It's that just hasn't happened to me.
And like natural progression of life.
I grew up in a Christian family that, um, believes in abstinence.
If I have sex, I'll go to hell. So that's the only time I ever heard about it.
Yes. I love Jesus.
But also I completely know I'm going to be a freak when I like lose my virginity
and I don't want to unleash on anyone. Who's not my husband. I'm just saying
I was always scared to just because like, um,
my parents were really young when they had me.
So it was just something that I didn't want to repeat. Um,
me and my twin were assaulted.
So I am a bit more careful about it, I guess,
in a sense,
I guess I am the way I am because I've been through what I've been through.
I'm a Christian and I think a large part of my life.
I like believe that premarital sex was a sin.
I'm like in this middle stage where I'm trying to figure it out and like reading
books and having conversations with people as people I think are doing more
research into that,
they're realizing that what they believed to be like condensed.
Isn't exactly condemned.
It says, have you ever had an orgasm? I'm a guy, you know, I fall short.
Yeah. Just skip it. No, I have not. Which is,
I guess that's probably why I'm like so anxious about that
is I don't, like, I've never done that.
In school. Growing up,
people would always make fun of those people who were like masturbating all the
time. So I thought it was something stupid.
So I honestly never did it till I was 18 years old.
I don't think I actually knew what I was doing though.
I just knew that like I would do something and it would feel really good.
And then I was like, I should do that more. Like,
so my mom offered to buy me my first vibrator. She was like, Hey, um,
so I know you're like older and you're independent and you have like needs,
please try to like, make sure it's not like $200,
but like I'll buy you like your first vibrator. And yeah. So she's amazing.
Would you rather, your first time deal with a Virgin or someone experienced?
Well, I haven't thought about that. Preferably someone with experience. I mean,
I feel like one of us should know what we're doing. Right.
I feel like I'm fine either way. I don't know.
I think there's just like the whole like insecurity thing that I would
constantly be comparing myself to like the other person's past partners or I
would be thinking like, am I doing this right?
Honestly, I'd rather my first time be with another Virgin,
just so I could feel comfortable though. We both don't know what we're doing.
It's more about the person, you know,
if you really are in love with them or you really have a connection with them,
it shouldn't matter.
Are you ever embarrassed about being a Virgin? Um,
I feel like the older I get I'm already 22.
So it's like kind of weird, but I, I'm not going to lie.
I do get embarrass about it sometimes. Yeah. Stigma against virgins,
right. That you're awkward or you're weird or there's something wrong with you.
You can't make eye contact, you can't hold a conversation.
And while I don't exude any of those things, like that's not me.
It's been my experience.
When I have gone on dates in the past where they will take the time to get to
know me and see like my glowing personality. And then they find out this piece,
I think is a very small piece about me. And all of a sudden,
my entire being is framed by that one thing, you know,
I try to set my expectations upfront and initially they're like, okay,
like I respect that. But the longer that we actually goes on,
they try to press you.
I did have this one guy call me the middle of night for five hours to tell me
that Christianity wasn't to be all God isn't to be old. I was being ridiculous.
So yeah, that ended.
So awkward.
Sometimes if there are people around you just trying to brag all the time,
kind of bragging about all the times they've had sex.
Like I don't even want to explain to them why.
So it's better just to hit that white lie. Yeah. I've had sex.
They're probably not going to quit. I think that they're questioning it more.
If you told them you were a Virgin,
then if you just lied and told them you're not a Virgin,
whenever we would be at a party or something like that. Oh, you're the Virgin.
You're the good guy. You're the goody. Good. You know, but I think.
Over time it's like, I'm braced, it's one of those things. It's like,
once you get to a certain point, it's like, I'm 29 shoot.
If I'm get to the 40 year old Virgin type thing, like I'm cool with it.
Have you had the chance to lose your security? The chose? Not to, yes.
I've had the chance. Yeah. I've had a chance to no.
Yeah, no. Um, I was in a social,
um, and just very bad at talking to people and also very oblivious to flirting.
There's always just those people that slide into your DMS and are like, Hey,
you want to have sex with me? I'm like stranger go away. No.
Yes, yes. It was there. And uh,
something just told me, like, that's just, it's just not worth it.
It was after like winter formal.
And I made out with this guy he, um,
finished and he, um,
wanted to continue and stuff, but I was just like, you know,
I'm okay. Do you ever regret.
Really?
Because a lot of those chances are like a party situation or like you're drunk,
they're drunk.
It's not like it was a romantic situation where it was super intimate and you
just missed out because you were scared.
So I really don't feel like I missed out in those scenarios.
Do you watch porn? When I was like younger, it was, um,
Tumblr born and it was like, this is like,
is anybody watching close my door,
lock my door and make sure no one knows this is happening. And then be like,
Oh my gosh, it's so awkward. I'm like, these people are doing it on camera.
I don't watch porn now.
But I think there was like a big part of my like life everyday,
like watching porn. I think like it did get to the point of addiction,
this constant reminding of like, this is really bad. This is really bad.
And you like beat yourself up about it.
And you're like not telling anybody about it because you just assume that none
of your friends are watching porn. Porn is also like something where like,
even like, I'm rethinking a lot when I like Morling lean towards, like,
I don't know if porn is bad when my viewpoint shifted. I just like,
there wasn't anything that I was fighting anymore.
So I just stopped watching porn.
If you can differentiate that porn isn't real life from the fact that it is like
porn as strictly an entertainment thing.
As long as you're consuming and moderation, shouldn't be a problem.
Are you afraid for your first time? Uh, yeah,
totally me and like someone else just being that intimate with each
other and revealing that much of yourself to someone else is just
intimidating. I am not.
Because I kind of dislike. If I trust this person,
then I shouldn't have a reason to be afraid.
I'm afraid of it not meeting my expectations.
I think since I've had so long to fantasize about it,
I have all these like visions of like, Oh my gosh, we're going to be like sat.
And she's with bros, pedals and kettles.
And I think I've amped it up a lot in my head.
I'm afraid I'm not going to get any pleasure out of it. Cause there's the huge,
like stereotype is it's pleasure for the guy and the girl doesn't get anything.
Um, I'm pansexual. And if I do end up having a male partner in that happening,
that would really suck.
So I did hear from friends that it's not going to be very pleasant and I know
it's going to be awkward,
but that's why I hope it's with the right person just so we can laugh it off
afterwards.
I see myself after like the wedding, um, you know,
where it's like going back to the room. Yeah.
And then there's a special moment where I actually,
this is actually something I think that would be really surprising for a lot of
people is I actually want to pray. This is gonna be crazy. It's cause I'm crazy.
I, I think it'll be a beautiful,
beautiful thing to be able to actually like pray and stuff like while do it
sounds crazy, but like, I just think it was so beautiful. I don't, so yeah.